the prime minister's know why we do
on continue to do you like and gay pride
à cette semaine vous avez un pays après
trois ans et demi en qui sort ça
affaiblit tout le monde il est le
monsieur breakes site du sénat voilà
trois ans que christian cambon suit à la
loupe les négociations entre l'union
européenne et le royaume uni la mission
que nous a confiée le président larcher
était de suivre pas à pas cette
incroyable
inénarrable surprenante négociations qui
nous conduit aujourd'hui à l'heure où je
parle à ne pas savoir exactement comment
la fin du film va se terminer
nourri par des dizaines d'auditions le
rapport du sénat détaille par le menu
les conséquences du bric site pour
l'économie française
le départ de la grande bretagne c'est
quelque chose d'assez catastrophique
pour tout un tas de profession pour nos
agriculteurs pour nos pêcheurs pour nos
entreprises pour les régions normandes
et hot france tout ceci est lourd de
conséquences et pour l'europe toute
entière au risque bien de donner des
idées aux autres et c'est un petit peu
ça que nous avons voulu suivre pas à pas
tout en restant dans les seules
compétences du sénat bien évidemment
[Musique]
on
mais
pierre-yves dachicourt est aux commandes
du rose de cassia un chalutier de
boulogne-sur-mer
c'est vraiment un monde à part dans la
famille on a toujours baigné dedans sur
mon père mon grand père sa remontée six
générations pêcheurs comme tous les
pêcheurs de boulogne
pierre-yves pêche le plus souvent dans
les eaux anglaises s'il travaille
aujourd'hui pour un armement du port il
voudrait faire construire son propre
bateau mais la perspective du drake site
l'inquiète
pour l'instant comme c'est des gros
investissements on attend de voir ce
qu'il va se passer
le pour l'instant on peut pour on peut
rien signé
passé entre 3 et 4 millions d'euros
ayari berry s'est réveillée matin dans
la joie et la bonne humeur
[Musique]
les matelots viennent de remonter leur
premier chat lui le poisson et trier et
conditionner directement à bord
puis ça va directement dans leur frigo
oh
personne la normale et du côté du côté
anglais go voir si ça va être dur contre
ça se passe et est ce que pas le maire
des solutions saas est de trouver un
arrangement pour les deux que dans les
angles et moralement lybohy perles et
puis nous on va y perdre aussi autant
essayer de s'arranger pour la carène
faire un résultat
si c'est un break si dieu a qu' on est
la plus grande explosion anglaise qu'on
se retrouve tout seul un endroit sarpoil
et on peut faire un chiffre d'affaires
courant scène pas tout payer les hommes
la bulle payer le gasoil sont donc
envisagées salaires plus dégoûtant parce
que c'est parce qu'on ne sait pas qu'il
est sinon c'est chaud
vous savez que 75% de la pêche des hauts
de france donc des pêcheurs de la côte
d'opale et bien été effectués dans les
eaux territoriales britanniques 75%
c'est vital pour eux c'est leur chiffre
d'affaires que vont-ils devenir
quel type d'accord pourront être passées
vous imaginez quand vous investissez sur
un bateau de pêche
l'investissement est énorme
[Musique]
à la cme on a remis à plus tard
plusieurs projets d'investissement à
cause du break site
un marin qui travaillent à terre ça lui
thierry je veux dire bonjour
[Musique]
éric gosselin et le directeur de cette
coopérative de pêcheurs qui emploie
aussi pierre-yves le capitaine du rose
de cassia aujourd'hui nous on travaille
nos bateaux travail ce qu'on appelle
nous nos zones de pêche historique c'est
celle à l'ab tout ce qui est le
l'embouchure de la tamise tout le long
des côtes anglaises ici et ce depuis des
générations je suis partie d'une
communauté ou depuis le moyen-âge en
pêche dans les eaux britanniques mais le
bric site laissent aussi présager d'une
nouvelle répartition des quotas de pêche
européens
c'est la règle de la stabilité relative
qui a réparti effectivement depuis la
création de l'europe
lucky acquis à déterminer la répartition
des quotas le pourcentage suivant lequel
le quota européen sera distribué le fait
qu'il ya un pays qui sortent
effectivement on pourrait considérer que
la règle de la stabilité relative est à
renégocier est effectivement là il ya
beaucoup de pays dont l'espagne
notamment qui attend qui attend qui
demande à revoir la règle de la
stabilité relative
il ya certains pays qui demandent
certains pays qui estiment avoir été mal
servis alors qu'effectivement la france
dans cette histoire de stabilité
relative est plutôt favorisés quand la
politique commune de la pêche qui est
une politique relativement intégré a été
mise en place
elle a été basée également sur des
quotas des quotas à l'époque où la
france avait beaucoup plus de navires
hier qu'elle n'en a aujourd'hui
donc qui dit breakes site dit également
réouverture de cette politique des
quotas
et puis on ne sait toujours pas même au
delà de l'accord du 17 octobre négocié
par barry johnson est validé pour la
première fois par le parlement
de quoi sera fait demain le futur accord
de libre échange
500 kilomètres plus au sud dans le
département de la manche
allez les filles allez allez allez
il est 5h30 du matin l'heure de la
traite pour hervé marie éleveurs
laitiers
allez on y va
elle était fille je veux plus 5h ce
matin comme tous les matins la
particularité de notre métier c'est que
la semaine commence le lundi matin et se
termine dimanche soir parce que les
vaches ça serait deux fois par jour
samedi à dimanche compris jabra exit c
c'est une décision qui ne nous
appartient pas puisqu'elle appartient au
gouvernement britannique
nous le risque qu'on y voit c'est que
nous allons certainement avoir des
conséquences sérieuses au niveau de
l'élevage
il faut rappeler que dans le département
de la manche nous avons quasiment une
vache sur cinq qui produit pour ce
marché là de manière directe ou
indirecte de manière directe c'est bien
évidemment vis-à-vis de l'ensemble des
contrats que nous avons avec les anglais
et puis de manière indirecte c'est à
dire quel sera le comportement des
anglais en termes de tourisme
quand le brésil sera mis en place si
c'est beaucoup moins intéressant pour
eux de venir en france parce que ça leur
coûte trop cher il y aura toute une
partie de consommation de produits
laitiers et viande aussi qui ne se fera
pas et ça c'est pas une paille
c'est notre premier marché c'est il faut
rappeler que ce marché là est beaucoup
plus proche de nous que paris
[Musique]
dans la manche deux coopératives
laitières vivent du commerce avec
l'angleterre la france est après les
pays bas le second fournisseur agricole
du royaume uni la france possède si je
puis dire avec la grande bretagne un des
rares excédents commerciaux que nous
puissions voir
il est de l'ordre de 12 à 13 milliards
d'euros ce n'est pas c'est important il
faut surtout pas le perdre
mais au delà des parts de marché le
break site soulève la question du
financement de la pac
je crois que la grande bretagne apporte
environ 15% du budget communautaire donc
à ce titre elle participe au financement
de la politique agricole commune
donc ça veut dire quelque part que la
politique agricole commune qui est si
précieuse pour nos agriculteurs va
perdre 15 % 15 % de ces financements
donc de deux choses l'une où il va
falloir se faire hara kiri de cette
somme
ou bien va falloir la répartir sur les
autres
moi
2 heures du matin le rose de cassia
rentrer au port après 24 heures en mer
dans ses cales une tonne de poissons
d'une valeur marchande d'environ 3000
euros pour pierre-yves c'est à peine de
quoi payer l'équipage et le carburant
[Musique]
la marchandise est déchargé d'ici
quelques heures
elle sera vendu à la criée premier port
de pêche français
boulogne-sur-mer est aussi la plaque
tournante pour les produits de la mer en
europe le matin j'arrive tout de suite
veille concurrentielle qu'est ce qui
s'est passé est ce que ramon le camion
est ce que rapporte le camion
toujours pour adapter les équipes la
journée de philippe lemaire a déjà
commencé il dirige une importante agence
de transport à boulogne important pour
lui c'est d'anticiper sur tous les
événements qui viennent qui viennent
avec leurs produits pour le pour
l'europe
ça veut dire que le process va changer
pour venir vendre du poisson en europe
il va falloir fournir un paquet document
qui va nous fait un paquet de temps on
est dans l'une de nos plateformes ici
qui a été mise en place pour le break
site aux cons et là on est sous un
entrepôt qui est complètement sous
douane et qui est prêt à accueillir nos
amis anglais sous douane ça veut dire
que pour gagner du temps
on peut décharger les camions on attend
que la douane viennent faire un contrôle
s'il le faut mais par contre dès qu'elle
aura 10 go on sera des gens d en
éclatement que si on avait pas cet
entrepôt la marchandise serait obligé de
rester dans les camions la douane frais
sans contrôle dans un camion est ce qui
permet pas d'aller plus vite on est
toujours toujours dans la rapidité
voilà les dde marque était endormie faut
savoir que le froid en dehors les
homards regardez ils sont encore vivants
alors homards vivants européen
tout est récolté hier en écosse c'est ce
matin à 6h30 chez nous à
boulogne-sur-mer
des noix de saint jacques un fournisseur
de noix de saint-jacques décosse qui
arrivent et dans trois minutes la
palette est démolie pour repartir sur
une autre planète pour servir les
magasins demain matin une ruche est une
fourmilière ici l'entreprise reçoit du
poisson de près de 20 pays d'europe du
nord dont une part importante du royaume
uni pour le livrer ensuite partout en
france
philippe lemaire est aux premières loges
du bauxite trois quatre cinq fois par
jour
aujourd'hui c'est les gens s'inquiètent
ce qu'il nous faut c'est avoir une date
précise une date butoir
mais là on nous emmène en bateau depuis
18 mois un moment faut arrêter je pense
que les anglais sont compliquées parce
qu'on va dire que c'est eux plus mais
moi j'aimerais bien avoir une date fixe
dire voilà on est prêt c'est telle date
au prendre nos dispositions au fait les
embauches on met en place et donc plus
grande que rungis la zone d'activités de
café cure voit transiter pas loin de 400
mille tonnes de poisson par an mareyeurs
négociant usines de transformation et
emploie près de 6000 personnes dans un
camion vous pouvez avoir quelquefois 30
expédition parce que le camion roule
quasiment plein ça veut dire que arrivé
en france il va falloir faire 30
déclarations d'un port et une
déclaration d'un port avec le contrôle
vétérinaire pas prendre entre 15 et 20
minutes
ça veut dire que sur un camion nous
pourrons perdre quelquefois 5 à 6 heures
si ça ne va pas vite même si on réduit
quelquefois de moi ça veut dire de une à
deux heures ça décale le départ du
poisson au lendemain matin donc ça veut
dire qu'il y aura des
des restrictions de gamme de produits
parce que la marchandise sera moins
fraîches et certains produits comme du
homard vivant et langoustines sont des
produits vivants et qui n'accepte pas
cette durée de transport supplémentaires
philippe en tout cas se dit prêt à
affronter le break site
il a notamment embauché un déclarant en
douane pour assurer demain le passage
des marchandises à la frontière même le
poisson qui est pêché par les
britanniques est transformé ici à
boulogne sur mer pour être ensuite
renvoyé chez les britanniques transformé
on sait que s'il y a un corps en jeu
pour la pêche
il y aura accord également à envisager
pour la transformation pour savoir si
les circuits sont toujours les mêmes et
là la question que l'on se pose c'est
est ce que les britanniques vont essayer
de faire transformer leurs poissons
ailleurs qu'à boulogne sur mer est ce
que ça sera l'enjeu des accords de pêche
vous comprenez les interrogations sont l
on sait que quand on repose tout sur la
table
tout est à renégocier
au départ de boulogne les camions à
destination du royaume uni emprunte un
axe fréquenté la liaison calais-douvres
barbato ou via le tunnel sous la manche
un tunnel par lequel transitent chaque
année 130 milliards d'euros de valeur
marchande
deux exemples premièrement le saumon
écossais qui vient est retranché et
fumer à boulogne sur mer de façon très
très large où les pièces de voitures
automobiles allemandes qui vont être
montés dans les usines bmw du kent c'est
environ 250 mille emplois qui sont
générés ou maintenus par cette activité
économique
lors de son audition au sénat il ya un
an le pdg d'eurotunnel ne cachaient pas
une certaine inquiétude
la france est donc dans une situation
tout à fait particulière elle redécouvre
ce qu'est une frontière terrestre avec
un pays tiers
il n'y a plus aujourd'hui de savoir
faire en france dans les services sur ce
qu'est la gestion d'une frontière
terrestre 2 million de camions de
millions de voitures avec un pays tiers
[Musique]
sur ces quatre écrans sont représentés
l'ensemble du système du tunnel sous la
manche
à gauche un terminal au centre le tunnel
eux-mêmes sous la mer et puis à droite
le terminal et donc on voit sur ces
numéros l'un les circulations des trains
on se dirige vers l'entrée du tunnel
sous la manche le site est très grand et
et 650 ha c'est grand comme orly ici on
s'imagine parfois que c'est juste un
tunnel est en fait non il ya un très
grand terminal c'est la voie ferrée la
plus sollicitée au monde
elle transporte cinq mille camions par
jour un quart du trafic entre le
royaume-uni et le continent tunnel est
déjà une frontière géographique et puis
une frontière shine gagnent ce qui est
nouveau avec le break si tu sais que les
marchandises qui aujourd'hui sont dans
la zone de tva intracommunautaire
pourrait selon la nature exacte de
l'accord avec auquel on va arriver être
déclarée en douane avant de passer par
par la frontière l'enjeu au lendemain du
break site maintenir une fluidité
maximale
le gestionnaire du tunnel investi 30
millions d'euros dans de nouvelles
infrastructures
les contrôles douaniers seront de
dématérialiser le fabricant de lusine
qui va déclarer sa marchandise dans le
système douanier transmettre cette
information à son transporteur lequel la
donne à son chauffeur qui arrivent ici
chez nous pour être prêt le jour j
les agents du tunnel font régulièrement
des simulations
je note l'immatriculation du chauffeur
donc sa plaque à vent et ensuite je vais
demander les documents douaniers au
chauffeur
merci monsieur
il reste encore des interrogations sur
les petits chargeurs qui font naître des
traversées occasionnels et qui ne voit
pas très souvent de la marchandise en
grande bretagne si jamais des chargeurs
n'ont pas fait de déclaration
ils seront refusés en arrivant chez nous
vous avez des tas de petits
transporteurs qui n'auront peut-être pas
la même habilité en matière de
digitalisation de transformation
numérique de leurs activités au
quotidien
moins de cinq minutes d'attentes à
eurotunnel cd fils qui se calculent rond
en kilomètres il est clair aussi que
dans les usines d'assemblage
ces cinq minutes d'attentes c'est une
perte de compétitivité sur l'ensemble de
la filière
retour dans la manche hervé marie a
troqué sa tenue d'éleveurs pour un
costume on va à cherbourg pour visiter
les infrastructures qui normalement
doivent être mises en place en vue de du
prochain réussite car hervé à une autre
casquette il préside le groupement de
défense sanitaire du département de la
manche
une association d'éleveurs qui veille à
la sécurité sanitaire et alimentaire au
sein de l'union européenne on respecte
les réglementations sanitaires de
l'union européenne donc qu'on sait que
nous sommes sur les mêmes bases il n'y a
pas de problème mais l'angleterre demain
n'aura plus l'obligation de respecter
ces normes sanitaires et nous devons
bien évidemment nous protéger
toutes ces entrées quoi hervé marie
redoute un jumping sanitaire de l'autre
côté du channel synonyme d'une
concurrence à bas coûts pour nos
agriculteurs et qui pourrait mettre en
danger le consommateur européen
cherbourg est une porte d'entrée pour
les marchandises en provenance du
royaume uni ou problème il est bien
sanitaire même si il est aussi en toile
de fond économique
hervé retrouve ses collègues éleveurs
ils veulent d'inspecter les
installations de contrôle vétérinaire
mise en place à la veille du bric cite
un responsable du ministère de
l'agriculture a fait le déplacement pour
les recevoir
pendant la traversée les chauffeurs
seront informés s'ils doivent passer au
contrôle ou pas en fonction de la nature
de leur chargement
s'ils n'ont pas besoin de contrôler
parce que c'est des matières
manufacturés qui n'ont pas besoin de
contrôler ils prennent la file verte et
sans bon cet entrepôt a été aménagé pour
contrôler les denrées alimentaires et
les animaux qui arriveront du royaume
uni une petite équipe de vétérinaires
vient tout juste d'investir les lieux
on entre sur le territoire millions
donc la réglementation est claire c'est
le premier point d'entrée sur territoire
du lit
qui fait d'elle un troll pour l'ensemble
des jours il ya du taf
vous avez ici en trop
les équidés et des petits et petites
années un laboratoire où on va pouvoir
majoritairement faire du visuel mais
préparez les échantillons
à
kadima
quand on est les éléments nécessaires
pour pouvoir le libérer ou du moins
statuer sur son capot donc là on est en
train de terminer on peut considérer qu
en terme d'infrastructures ces prêts
maintenant c'est un problème de gestion
politique le flou n'est pas permis et le
flou et trop risqué parce que de toute
façon le sanitaire nous amènera à voir
des carences économique si jamais les
pas bien traité me souviens j'avais été
rapporteur du dossier sur la vache folle
et je sais la faible qualité du réseau
d'épidémiosurveillance anglais il ya
tout à craindre d'une fragilité de la
sécurité sanitaire des produits venant
d'angleterre
le port de cherbourg accueille 850
escale par an ici tous ne voient pas
d'un mauvais oeil le break site
ce matin yannick mille est le directeur
du port supervise l'arrivée d'un ferry
irlandais et les pilotes qui arrivent
qui vient de dublin et qui est de
l'accompagner régis ferries et il arrive
ce matin puisqu'il aurait dû venir hier
mais décalé par des raisons météo mais
on arrive on est en train de monter dans
la voiture tout de suite
ils viennent de marennes navire ils sont
pas de faire des réglages pour poser la
porte sur la passerelle
de manière à ce que la pente soit
adéquat pour déchargement et chargement
des poids lourds à cherbourg ont misé
sur l'irlande en pariant que le break
site va avoir un impact sur les routes
maritimes 80% des échanges de
marchandises entre l'irlande et le
continent européen transitent
aujourd'hui par le royaume uni par
exemple un contenaire expédier du port
de dublin
débarqué à liverpool puis transportés
par camion à douvres rejoint enfin
calais par le tunnel sous la manche
le tout sans quitter l'union douanière
ce trait d'union entre l'irlande et le
continent est baptisé l'inde bridge pont
terrestre en français plus de 3 millions
de tonnes de marchandises l'empruntent
chaque année mais avec le break site et
le retour de barrières douanières dans
les ports britanniques
une partie du fret irlandais pourrait
choisir de contourner le royaume uni et
se rediriger vers les ports normands et
bretons s'il ya une montée d'activité
générée par les embauches
supplémentaires pour finaliser ces
embauches il faut quand même qu'on a une
vision claire des accords dubrac site
pour savoir vers où on se dessiner c'est
tout le la difficulté de ce break site
où il est temps qu'on arrive à une vraie
porte de sortie
[Musique]
nous retrouvons christian cambon le
sénateur a rendez vous chez
l'ambassadeur dû royaume uni en france
[Musique]
on vient vous occuper alors que les
journées sont chargées tout à fait parce
que le charger c'est normal les ja de 20
[Musique]
quelle que soit l'issue du bric site
christian cambon veut déjà penser à
l'après il ya un après et c'est après
c'est déjà sur cette échéance que nous
souhaitons préparé avec des
manifestations concrètes qui montreront
que la grande bretagne ne dérive pas au
sein de l'atlantique mais reste malgré
tout une puissance au sein de l'europe
au lendemain du bric site
l'europe aura jusqu'à trois ans pour
négocier un nouvel accord de libre
échange avec le royaume uni
le gros problème c'est qu'on n'arrive
pas à se projeter en fait puisqu'on ne
sait jamais quelles seront quelles
seront les réactions britannique
on comprend là à l'heure qu'il est que
le parlement est très divisé et qu'il
l'est depuis des années veulent t'ils
réellement prendre une décision si nous
avons des difficultés à négocier avec
boris johnson ou d'autres trois ans ça
va être très court pour entre guillemets
l'activité économique européenne et
mondiale
nous allons voir la première économie
mondiale qui pendant trois ans voire
plus va être dans je dirais
l'incertitude et ça ça coûte très cher
[Musique]
savait pas trop
paquet